windy but cooler than yesterday the
highs only in the high 90s outside right
now for our current temperatures but the
winds continue to blow the sustained
wind at 21 miles per hour we've seen
them up to 41. currently outside 98 in
centennial hills 91 and someone 94 for
the lakes 95 for downtown and north las
vegas we're also around 99 for green
valley 100 though for henderson 94 for
rhodes ranch so really not too bad for
our temperatures this is below normal
for this time of year 103 is our average
and some of us not even reaching 194 for
prep right now 98 for boulder city uh
right at the century mark for laughlin
102 out there in death valley that's
actually pretty nice in death valley
because they've been at 118 to 120
lately weather now radar showing those
storms way off into the grand canyon
flagstaff into utah and they are
drifting towards the northeast the tail
end of these ones though starting to
make their way down towards southern
lincoln county now as we go to our
future cast here's the deal we do have a
chance according to our futurecast that
we could pick up an isolated isolated
storm
possibly over the overton arm for this
evening we'll keep our eye on that i'll
stay in just to watch that this will
move off and drift off towards the east
that's just an isolated cell on itself
nothing in las vegas that'll be mainly
east of us and after tomorrow it really
starts to dry out across the region so
here's the other big story wind first
now this your overnight lows tomorrow
morning will only be in the mid 70s all
across las vegas so it's going to be a
great morning start
in fact that's going to be in the 70s
for these next few days here your
regional lows 64 for prop cooler for you
73 boulder city your morning start 81 in
lafayette so here's your forecast like
we talked about 75 overnight hazy and
breezy though so we'll keep around
those breezy winds for at least later on
this evening and some breezes around
also tomorrow morning too
95 for tomorrow that's our high hazy and
cooler so expect widespread smoke
tomorrow 103 is our normal we're going
to be below that at 95 we're not going
to reach 100 degrees tomorrow we're not
going to reach 100 degrees officially on
friday in fact we'll probably see triple
digits officially
maybe this weekend definitely next week
but these next few days here are going
to feel glorious in the morning with
those